and let's read the big news from
timcast.com
senate republicans and mansion block
women's health protection act quote make
no mistake it is not roe v wade
codification it is an expansion it wipes
500 state laws off the books said
senator joe manchin so let's just do
this that's simple the democrats were
acting like this was going to be federal
codification of roe v wade that's not
true and i will just go straight to it
with section 4 of the bill which is 3755
which states there can be no limitations
or requirements on
a prohibition on abortion after fetal
viability when in the good faith medical
judgment of the treating healthcare
provider continuation of the pregnancy
would pose a risk to the pregnant
patient patient's life or health i just
want to pause real quick and assess that
provision right there and just say
it says after viability meaning the baby
can survive
you're saying you can
terminate the baby
even if it could survive
because the mother's health may be at
risk i understand if their argument is
end the pregnancy if it said and the
pregnancy but preserve the life of the
baby but it didn't say that quite
literally they're like we can kill a
baby if the woman would be medically
harmed by the pregnancy why not why not
just take the baby out and let it live
maybe they're assuming that if the
removal of the baby would kill the woman
then but either way they're gonna have
to take the body out whether it's alive
or not exactly also um
this idea of an exemption for health
this is a term which is used very
vaguely so they're actually able to say
something along the lines of well we
have determined that this woman might be
negatively affected with respect to
something like depression if she has a
child therefore
the abortion is a medical necessity i i
think it's just they need to meet their
blood quotas for to sacrifice the moloch
yeah that's all it is yeah blood quotas
to moloch
but i think that i think it has to be in
person so i don't know if it would count
oh yeah i think i'm wrong
um
yeah bloodlust is no joke
that's from eating all the animal meat
i don't think so there are a lot of
people who eat animal eat that don't
can you tell if this meant like if the
woman would die if the baby was taken
out of the body at eight months or is
this like if the woman would survive if
the body faster viability it's the
weirdest thing what is viability it
means the baby can survive on its own
without like a breathing apparatus or
like an incubator or something there are
humans that are considered viable humans
that need a breathing apparatus
viability just means the baby can
survive without the mother at this point
maybe that does mean they got to put it
in a icu and a respirator or something i
just i really don't get the argument
that it's like
this baby could survive
but we should kill it i don't i
genuinely don't get it i don't
understand i mean it's the purpose
though when you think about it because
most people they're not they're not
going out and having an abortion because
they feel as if something is living off
their body that they don't want to live
off their body it's because they don't
want to be a parent
so viability or non-viability isn't
really a relevant argument to them i
mean but it also just speaks to why they
haven't actually gone forward i mean
this could have they could have codify
it for the past 50 years but they're not
going to because it puts democrats in
this weird position on where exactly
they draw this line and clearly they
they drew the line joe's like so far
out of field that
we get someone like joe manchin mansion
is
like he is the savior of the democratic
party
they the reason they don't codify roe v
wade is that they need it as a wedge
issue so all of a sudden joe manchin
comes along and he's like oh i can't do
it and all the democrats are like we're
trying but joe manchin won't let us
keep trying exactly exactly and the
republicans do the same thing they did
it with obamacare they could have
repealed it but they were like no no no
don't do it don't do it it riles people
up so do you think it's convenient for
them that joe manchin is standing in the
way or do you believe that he is
actually actively trying to impede it
for that reason uh i i i think it's a
perfect storm look joe mentions a west
virginia democrat which means he's got
to be moderate to right leaning on these
issues exactly if but i i got to be
honest i don't see joe manchin getting
reelected that just sounds insane to me
at this point
west virginia went like 86 percent for
trump this dude i just don't see it so
he might just be like i'll play my role
you know
make give the democrats a chance to keep
complaining about these things and never
do anything about it i uh pulled up an
article from washington post that says
fetal viability is generally considered
to be around 23 or 24 weeks which is
like what is that five to six months and
uh there's no universal consensus some
hospitals will resuscitate the baby
actively treat babies born in 22nd week
so it's somewhere around there i don't
know where they got this data but this
is washington post so i can understand
if there's a baby that's considered
viable at a certain age and the mom's
like dying for some reason and they're
like we're gonna we're gonna abort the
pregnancy and then the baby dies i'm
like okay well you know these things
happen they were trying to save life i
just don't understand the idea that they
don't explain that they don't break it
down there's no there should be
limitations there it should be that it
should include that provision and an
attempt to save the life of the baby
should be there's a big difference
between six-month viability and
eight-month viability that you're like a
human being ready to just bounce outside
the skin at nine months so like
yeah i i don't know the word viability
is very weird because if the power goes
out then what does that word even mean
anymore
so if a baby is born at eight months but
they need to be hooked up to a
respirator or breathing machine and the
power goes out could you make the same
argument you'd have to say like well we
don't have we don't have a breathing
machine can this thing survive on its
own with modern technology which in this
theoretically should be no electricity
what is it called uh what's the what's
the pump they call it they put on your
face and pump it it's like a it's a
breast
respirator mask the pump the pump face
mask yeah pump face mask that's exactly
it that's the medical term actually it's
true but they could put that on the baby
yeah so if you if oxygen goes out then
you need to figure something else out
and one of the options would be this
mask that they use when they're
performing resuscitation when they're
performing cpr they use this
it's a handheld mask to pro to deliver
breaths to someone so you can help
someone breathe if the power goes out
you just need to do it are republicans
going to try and do the inverse and ban
abortion federally that's a good
question i'm not sure yeah i mean i hope
so but i think the republican party is
really pretty weak
but i mean i mean the whole point of roe
vs wade is that it gives it back to the
state so i mean ending
or yeah or returning it um so
i mean ultimately that would i mean
because i mean that's the whole reason
why we're kind of in this mess in the
first place in terms of
the this freakish outrage and them going
to supreme court justice house because
they there's this misconception that
roe v wade ends and then all of a sudden
there's no more abortions just anywhere
and and so i think at least on the state
on the state level obviously a place
like not like california is not going to
do that because it's just so
heavily down but
you would think
that the states would that are
republican controlled so then maybe then
republicans on the federal level
wouldn't feel that pressure necessarily
i think
this attempt right here i mean democrats
just lost any any any
i guess the idea is we tried to do it
but because of mansion you better go
vote which i just don't see being
reality they're making it about the
filibuster yeah
well they could get best filibuster
anyway
exactly pointless it's pointless well
then that's because they they always
just fall back to the filibuster because
they have no other thing to to fall back
on when when their things fail
so was there a filibuster involved in
this process that nope they just didn't
get the votes yeah but even if they did
the filibuster would allow they would
need 60 votes it's not going to happen
so there was this really funny thread
from politico where this democrat was
talking about the economy
and giving a speech to other democratic
party members and politicians and it was
like the other democrats were shocked
and they were like but nothing this is
not coming up in the polls like who
cares about inflation in the economy and
they were like trying to explain to them
it's the economy stupid
but you actually have democrats who are
sitting there right now being like if
there's one thing every american truly
cares about this election it's abortion
meanwhile there's a guy like i have no
guess and they're like but abortion
another person goes i'm hungry yes yes
but abortion and then someone says
there's no baby formula you could have
aborted it's like is that that's fair
it's their argument and and not only
abortion right so i've said before i
mean it's all murder but if you're gonna
look at the perspective of your average
american person there are even many
people who would consider themselves to
be in favor of it or or not in favor of
banning it who would say nine months
that's pretty insane but that's the hill
that they're choosing to die on right
now we're we're more we're more less
restrictive than than europe i mean i
mean we had that whole you know funny
clip of bill maher this week saying i
didn't know this did you know this and
his panels are no we didn't know about
europe about how how more restrictive
they are bill bill maher
has made
his the it's so sad
you know the end of his career is
basically like are you guys hearing
about this thing that happened years ago
i just found out about this thing called
the google it's like bill bill we had
the conversation about europe two months
ago
this dude doesn't have google he is
never heard of he has rules new rules
yeah no rule everyone
you need to google search something
before you talk about it on your show
okay let's give bill credit he is just
the human version of microsoft explorer
there it's fine that's not a big deal i
wanted to
that abortion is murder technically it's
not it's just a type of killing right
now but just just for specifics
you could if you want to be pedantic you
feel like it's murder but it's legally
not me
i mean everyone that was killed in the
holocaust was murdered it's even though
it was illegal it's like uh you could
argue that too but yeah i mean murder is
a specific legal definition
it's like when stewie on family guy said
it's not that i want to kill lois it's
that i don't want her to be alive
anymore
i want her not to be alive no being so
so murder is if i understand an unlawful
killing and i'm saying the law of our
nation might not protect those lives but
that's no law at all
yeah i see you understand you think it
is murder but legally it's not
our country our country's laws are not
recognized yeah that's why our laws are
wrong that's the whole problem
this is why it doesn't recognize it as
such i think it's really stupid to
define murder as unlawful but i
understand why they would because the
death penalty they would like they argue
is legal but i still think you could
call all of these things murder well
like the intentional killing of their
personal war is where it's like those
they're not murderers in war they're
killers but they're not murderers
ah
i think they're all murderers ah man no
way no if you're protecting yourself and
someone's attacking you
yeah not necessarily
but i think i think the point is ian so
if you feel like the end we're in the
ussr putting people up against the wall
technically that was legal right but i
wouldn't say oh they're not a murderer
because that was legal that person's
still this is a good point i would say
maybe it's the the um aggressive
intentional killing of another person
even then war like you go into a a
like a machine gun nest and wipe
everybody out with a grenade
intentionally based yeah that's that's
not murder you're killing for a living
you know that is an interesting point i
wonder i wonder where we could find the
like where's the actual line and what
would what would be a murder sure i mean
but i would still definitely say an
innocent unborn child you kill them you
fallen out of the categories you made an
excellent point that a government could
make it legal and then do it and it say
hey it's not murder because we made it
legal but like just because it's legal
doesn't mean it's right or good exactly
exactly well if you look at like
china i dare say that the mountains of
skulls there and in like pol pots
cambodia would say a different story
because those were technically just
victims of the government it wasn't
really a murder right i mean yeah our
who was maybe a victim of the government
wasn't even victory right it wasn't even
victim well they wouldn't say they're
victims it was necessary
cleansing of of
undesirability everybody wants to
justify why they get to kill somebody
exactly that's suspicious
i understand war though
in times of war consider everything out
the window you want to talk about your
rights good luck when you're in a war
you can talk all day and night about the
rights you do have and and i think a
person has inalienable rights
but someone with force can try to
infringe upon those rights and you'll
have to fight for them that's why that's
why i thought it was funny when i was in
the marine corps and going through the
training because we we were taught the
geneva conventions and the rights that
we had uh under that and we're i'm just
thinking
who would actually
recognize recognize that
no one's gonna recognize that i mean if
we're truly going up against an enemy
that hates us i was talking about
vietnam the other day and i brought the
mylai massacre i don't know if you guys
are aware it was like one of the
greatest
massacres perpetrated by american troops
ever in the history of the united states
it was like i think 500 vietnamese
villagers women children were burned
alive and killed by like a hundred
troops like a bunch of yeah it was it
wasn't like 20. it was yeah there's a
bunch of i think helicopter gunships
were mowing people down i think it was a
company only one guy got in trouble
william law's cali jr he was a
lieutenant and uh they charged him with
like life in prison multiple life in
prison three days later nixon
uh commuted his sentence and sentenced
him to uh house arrest and then he never
really got no one got in trouble for it
because it's like when you're at war the
geneva convention is out i mean for the
most part out the window you do what you
got to do to survive these guys had
snapped psychologically and took it out
on the villagers but like you put them
in the jungle and you make them go crazy
how can you really blame them for it i
don't know that's a tough question
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8 pm
and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there is a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there